SPEAKER 1: If you're like
many, you get a new phone
every two years.
With some napkin math, you'll
see this means about half
of your users will get
a new phone this year.
What happens when your
user gets a new phone?
Google Play will reinstall your
app, and if you do nothing,
you'll create a cold welcome.
You'll show a blank
login form-- like they're
a total stranger who has
never created an account.
No one enjoys that.
There's a few ways you
can give a warm welcome.
You can simplify log in by
using Google Sign In, Smart
Lock and Autofill,
and you can easily
move all of your app
settings to the new phone
by using Auto Backup.
You're probably familiar
with Google Sign In.
Instead of needing a
username and password,
users press a single button to
securely log them into your app
with their g-mail account,
or any email address--
and if you enable it, they
can even skip the button.
By adopting Google
Sign In, you can
lift registration and
activation as well as retention
in your iOS, web and
Android applications.
For users with a password,
create a warm welcome
with Smart Lock for Passwords.
Smart Lock is a
password manager,
and it will offer to save users'
passwords when they log in.
If they decline, it
won't bug them again.
But if they accept, it
securely stores their password
in the cloud.
Your Android and
web applications
can then fetch this
password programmatically
so you don't have to
show them a login form.
Smart Lock is backwards
compatible from API 9
or Gingerbread.
In a case study, one company
found a 20% reduction
in login related support
requests by adding Smart Lock,
and it really warms up
the user experience.
Android O adds the
Autofill Framework.
Autofill works just
like in Chrome,
offering to save
form content when
users enter their passwords
or other information.
As a developer, you can get
ready by adding Autofill hints
and setting up a digital asset
link between their website
and Android application.
This is a JSON file that you
host on your web server, which
allows Autofill
services to share
Autofill data between
your web and Android app.
But how do you move content
that isn't behind a login?
For example, in Gmail we show
a welcome to our new users.
You expect this to not repeat on
your new phone, and it doesn't.
We used our cloud backup service
to build this functionality.
And because offering
a warm welcome
is important to
Android users, we
offer it to Android
apps for free.
Auto Backup saves
all of your apps
changed files, up to
25 megabytes, nightly.
When your app installs
again, the files
are downloaded
before it launches.
Restores aren't limited to
play installs, and happen even
when you side load from
Android Studio or ASB.
To learn more about configuring
Auto Backup, including
how to exclude files,
check out the documentation
on developer.android.com.
Remember, Auto Backup
is not a good place
to store information like
passwords or credit card
numbers, and definitely
not for storing
sensitive information
like medical records
or financial data.
If your app already
has a different way
to transfer settings
to a new phone,
check to make sure
you're transferring
all of the settings.
It's easy to forget a
few, and users really
want that warm welcome.
Thanks for watching.
I've included links
in the description
for details about
how to integrate
any of these features.
And be sure to check out
our previous video on making
your app Autofill ready.
See you next time.